c'est une grande société avec plein
d'employés et la DRH avoir le boss il
dit on a un problème on a trop
d'employés il va falloir enfin il y a
nous en France il faut engager des
handicapés quoi bah ok bah faites des
entretiens donc il y a plein
d'handicapés qui passent qui passent et
là il y a un mec qui arrive plutôt pas
d'handicap mais marche bien il parle
bien même plutôt beau gosse elle dit
mais monsieur excuse-moi c'est quoi
votre handicap à vous il y a aussi moi
je suis un ancien militaire moi j'arrive
du Mali là et j'ai marché sur une mine
et puis j'ai plus de couilles il y a
plus rien quoi donc sinon tout le reste
marche très très bien ok bah vous êtes
engagés quoi bon venez demain à 11h ça
commence pas à 9h chez vous d'ici mais
pour vous c'est mieux que vous venez à
11h non mais madame vous voyez bien que
j'ai pas d'handicap ok c'est si les
autres ils commencent à 9h je viens à 9h
non 9h 11h 9h 11h un an et demi mais
pourquoi vous voulez pas que je vienne à
9h et dis parce que dans cette boîte de
9 heures à 11h on a l'habitude de se
gratter un peu les couilles
[Applaudissements]